[موسيقى]
بالنسبه عدي ما شفت
الصور لليوم نهائيا
واصلا لما تواصلت معه اشخاص معنيه عندنا
يعني تربطنا باللي يصير بالبلد بعد ان
خرجنا يعني جماعتنا
نكره وتماما انه ذولا عدي قصي اتضح بعد
مرور مده اذا اقول لك بعد مرور ثلاث سنوات
انه اخفوا الموضوع عنا
وباستمرار يقولوا لنا زينين ضيقاتلون
حفاظا على معنوياتنا انه احنا كنا ايضا في
ظروف صعبه النساء
يعني نساء تركوا البلد مع اولادهم كبارهم
موجودين بالبلد فكانوا
يحافظون على انه النساء تبقى معنوياتها
عاليه
مو ثلاث سنين سنتين وشوي لا
يعني هنا انطوني الخبر كما هو لكن المشاهد
[موسيقى]
عرفتي حقيقه ما جرى
كيف تم القبض عليهما وقتلهما كذلك
المعلومات موجوده بالانترنت ارجعها هاي
المعلومات ما اريد اتصفحها وتوجعني وما
اريد اذكرها اطلاقا اكيد متوفر الجمع ولكن
انت شقيقه عدي وقصي اكيد لديك جانب اخر من
القصه غير متوافر في الانترنت اني بالكتاب
ذكرت تفاصيل
يعني اني ما راح اقول لك
اني يهمني
ان تخدم الحقائق كما هي
ونخلص من القال والقيل
وشاينعم كانت اكوي والواشي موجود والواشي
يتنقل بين دول اجنبيه واحيانا دول عربيه
رغم انه ضاق الخناق عليها
لديك الدليل القاطع بانه هو هذا هو الشخص
[موسيقى]